ghosts are real  that much I know I've seen them all my  life what you'd admire Edith this is my  sister  I don't think she's the right choice you  have to trust me  Thomas your bride is frozen I run your  hot bath  there are parts of the house that are  unsafe  the house as old as this one becomes in  time a living thing never go below this  level  it starts holding onto things has anyone  died in this house specific deaths  violent deaths own vested interest the  seed was caution keeping them alive when  they shouldn't be  if you're here with me she does  everything  do we have the days must we  yes you have no idea what they do what  do you want  I have to leave  you have nowhere else to go this is your  home now